[Musique]
kaoutar ennour sont deux des
aventurières qui ont cette année décidé
de se lancer dans l'aventuré pékin
express
une aventure un peu particulière puisque
tourné en plusieurs parties à cause de
la qu'ovide voilà ils nous voient
arriver avec des masques tout de suite
ça les effraie ou tard et sa fille nous
ont été éliminés lors du cinquième
numéro du programme
un coup dur qui a été l'occasion pour
les deux femmes de faire le point sur
les moments marquants de l'aventuré
c'est un rêve qu'ont réalisé les 2 et
quoi de faire avec sa mère s'il ya des
bons moments il ya eu aussi des moments
plus difficiles à gérer fois elle comme
lorsqu'elles ont traversé la grèce on
peut dire qu'il y avait beaucoup de
racisme par rapport à nous les deux
femmes se sont retrouvés face à des
grecs distant voire menaçant la famille
chez qui on a dormi nous a dit que les
grecs en ce moment à cause du conflit
gréco turque avait un problème avec tout
ce qui est maghrébin et arabe
on a reçu beaucoup d' insulte de
remarques de reproches des séquences que
les téléspectateurs n'ont pas vu à
l'antenne alors pékin express m6 at-elle
dissimuler des attaques racistes
kaoutar ennour d'être avec nous merci
déchiré merci nous remercient de la ou
tard vous étiez magnifique nos émissions
non mais c'est vrai je suis très content
de vous voir les magnifiques ayant rien
et c'est vrai qu'on dirait une pub pour
eux zoko paul je sais que vous étiez
très ému par ce qui s'est passé en grèce
qu'est ce qui s'est passé est ce que
pourrait nous raconter parce que je vous
le dis ça a été horrible
alors aujourd'hui j'ai la réponse de m6
m6 a dit on n'avoue rien cacher dans
pékin express dans notre émission où le
racisme est un sujet nous en avions
parlé notamment avec l'émission et
jackson richardson aux états unis bien
au contraire si nous avions une séquence
voilà à mettre on l'aurait dit ce mois
là donc ils ont remis la séquence mais
les épisodes en grèce ont été très
compliqués pour tous les candidats
les locaux les repousser par peur de
l'aco vide ça a été le cas pour kaoutar
ennour ils l'ont dit dans les
commentaires est-ce que ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec ça alors je suis d'accord
au sens où c'est vrai qu'on arrive dans
un pays où les gens ont peur c'est vrai
qu'on est dans une salle des mille
mondial tout le monde a peur ça on est
d'accord
maintenant c'est vrai que nous la
différence des autres binômes on en a
parlé avec eux on a subi des insultes
on a subi des menaces des qu'enfin des
locaux qui nous disait on va vous
appeler la police
bouger d'ici vous faites pas de stop ici
c'est impossible pourquoi alors
qu'est-ce que vous disais et y'a pas en
fait c'étaient des trucs comme ça
c'était des repousses des repousses il
avait même qui a insulté en anglais ils
s'arrêtaient devant nous on était sur
une route nationale ils s'arrêtaient
devant nous ils nous regardaient autant
bailly verrouiller les ports si l'une
avec la production où j'aurais dit vous
a dit en grèce que les gens avaient du
mal je cite avec les maghrébins et les
arabes à cause du conflit que des
coutures sont à bas les locaux les le
couple alors faut savoir qu'on a vécu
deux pékin express on a vécu le premier
qui étaient en afrique s'est super bien
passé où tous marcher comme sur des
roulettes malgré nos difficultés
avancées parfois et nos galères comme
vous savez qui c'est voilà mon actif et
avait su la jouer plus dur voilà après
on a été rapatriée on n'est pas reparti
six mois après mais pour préserver la
sécurité tout ce qui va avec donc ils
ont choisi un pays en europe où un
endroit qui soit pas très loin de la
france assure pouvoir revenir
du coup ça a été la grèce quand on est
arrivés en grèce
déjà il y avait comme l'a dit nous il y
avait le problème du coc vite donc il y
avait aussi des masques il y avait la
dispensation sociale il y avait le
conflit entre la grèce et la turquie
et puis avait une autre couleur de peau
qui
qui faisait plus turc que français quoi
donc à ce moment là bas c'est vrai qu'on
en a on en a bavé le couple de grec
antique on a dormi ils m'ont dit le
couple degré que qui voudraient dormir
vous a dit quoi alors c'est ce monsieur
justement c'est on en a parlé avec eux
après ça et on leur a dit que du coup
ils ont trouvé des voies on a expliqué
le principe du lion leur a dit qu'il en
avait du mal à trouver des voitures
aussi mais vous savez que vous êtes très
typé déjà nous mêmes enfin c'est
compliqué ici parce qu'ils ont du mal
avec les turcs nous ça va par rapport à
ça ça nous dérange pas mais c'est vrai
que ça fait cheap et ils ont du mal avec
tout ce qui est fait à dessein des
personnes abattues ce moment qu'ils sont
pas occidentaux du coup orientaux et bah
ils vous repousse parce que voilà ils
ont peur de vous et il estime que vous
pas vous êtes inconsciemment lié à la
turquie donc bah c'est pour ça que vous
dit vous devez sûrement avoir plus de
mal que les autres
alors est ce que il ya des gens qui
reproche à m6 et avoir dissimulé ces
attaques nicolas pernikoff vous pensez
quoi vous ah oui bien sûr je pense que
oui et puis la question que j'ai envie
de vous poser vous c est ce que c'est le
reflet de ce que vous avez vécu est ce
que vous pensez qu'il ya eu des coupes
est ce que vous pensez qu'ils ont voulu
protéger parce que le prétexte d'une
copie du show bien l'entendre mais à un
moment donné c'est pas avec les listes
un vrai conflit sur place et c'est vrai
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui disent
qu'en ce moment en grèce les gens sont
liés de montée du racisme
oui mais ils l'ont fait mais bien sûr
qu'ils l'ont fait oui on pensait qu'ils
ont monté mais bien sûr qu'ils ont bien
sûr qu'ils vont t'ils berd est ce que
vous avez des infos on n'a rien ressenti
dans l'épisode
et c'est vrai que j'ai entendu tout ce
que vous dites en grèce il ya eu un
mouvement d'extrême droite hop doré il
ya une montée du racisme c'est vrai il y
avait un procès au doré il ya du racisme
et c'est vrai que exactement ya là en
grèce il ya la peur de l'autre la peur
de l'étranger avec l'aco vide en plus
ils sont pas méchants non on a vraiment
qu'on avait le contact avec eux sacem
oui
comme les danses là d'ailleurs alors
justement regarder une séquence émotion
vous avez dans ces mêmes même en dehors
de ce que on n'a pas vu même les gens ne
m'atteint nous faisait le petit déjeuner
avec des petits messages sur les
gobelets cod petit tapenade y avait des
messages sur les gober barrez-vous de là
[Rires]
c'est très sympa en fait c'est le
premier abord c'est forcément lui on a
peur de vous c'est un peu comme raciste
par ce domaine et vous qu'est-ce que
vous parce qu'il ya des gens voilà qui
ont dit que m6 elle n'avait pas monté
ces images est ce que vous pouvez le
comprendre de la part d'eads si vous
dites vous bien évidemment qu'on
comprend qu'elle enlève ça c'est très
dévalorisant pour l'émission c'est pas
bien le racisme est condamnable sous
toutes ses formes donc normal qu'il y
ait enlevé et même dévalorisant pour les
grecs donc c'est vrai qu'il ya une
volonté de l'émission et vous protéger
et ne pas montrer ça comme par ailleurs
et tourne 48 heures pour un 1h50
démission et qu'il ya des choix à faire
sur le mental ou bien sûr qui privilégie
sa vélo avant moi j'ai eu la chaîne
aussi qui en substance me donner les
mêmes excuses vous mais qui m'a dit
aussi qu'ils avaient aucune séquence
profondément raciste dans les roches
dans ma question c'est est-ce que ces
séquences elles ont été filmées par la
production c'était en off alors on a été
filmée constamment maintenant on voit
pas ce qui est filmé dans
dans la boîte ou pas en fait donc du
coup ben nous on a le tout cas la
journaliste et le cas mais la caméra
masire embrasse mal en vue donc alors
ils s'étaient pas où j'étais c'était
quoi c'était plus des gestes que vous
lisez ce que vous avez insultés oui on a
été même on a même été ensuite et par
les pompiers en quoi c'était mon devoir
c'était des gones qui veut dire beaucoup
de la cvo permet de dire c'est que
c'était le cas mais les pièces qui vont
avec
je parle comme ça mais il y avait les
gestes et puis c'est c'est yves des
autres membres n'a alors qu'ils
n'étaient que des trucs comme ça et
c'est elle est vraiment à l'espagnol en
grec
on est d'accord et j offre ici et donc
vous avez senti que c'était contre vous
ah oui oui ben j'ai ressenti très ému ce
matin avec mais j'ai su comme on dit
mais l'équipe et m'ont dit que quand ils
vous avez eu au téléphone il était très
ému de ce passé les changer en fait le
problème réel aujourd'hui moi je vais
pas dénigrer m6 où pékin express parce
que j'ai fait une émission mais hors
normes et est magnifique franchement
tout le monde rêverait de faire pékin
express est en tout cas moi je les
préférés des vécus j'ai préféré le vécu
que le voir à la télé chose qui est
réellement normal parce qu'on peut pas
tout montrer
ça vous a plaidé ce comportement mais
c'est vrai que bon bain malheureusement
on est arrivés en situation où ça
n'allait pas et ça nous a freinés dans
notre notre aventure est aux aguets cher
pour votre petit matin moi c'est vrai
que quand vous dites qu'on a été on a
été touchés par quand on a été en appel
avec votre équipe on a commencé une
aventure où on va pas se mentir c'est
sans se vanter
on se débrouille assez bien orange avait
gagné deux étapes et on a on a kiffé
notre aventure jusqu'au bout d'ailleurs
même en grèce 1 faut pas se mentir c'est
en fait on perd des goûts al aventure
parce que justement on pouvait pas la
vivre pleinement et ce n'était pas de
notre ressort ça veut dire que on nous
dit souvent mais en fait finalement
c'est parce que vous étiez nul c'est pas
qu'on est nul c'est qu'on n'arrivait pas
à avancer et que on va pékin express et
du stop si on n'a pas de voiture et nous
on ne fait pas c'est à dire que moi moi
humble - là je vais en grèce en ce
moment en afrique et il faut que j'aille
avec épaules il faut que j'aille en
overboard quoi ça va pas du tout voilà
ils vont pas là où ce genre la police
était compliqué pour vous rappelez vous
qu en laponie
ah oui mais voilà des serres qui m'ont
pas pris non arrivée l'ayraultport avec
votre faciès rappelez vous va si c'était
pas le pas du tout facile à masisi je me
rappelle ce qui a eu rappelez vous que
vous avez été interpellé par la police à
la fin c'est normal ils ont vu un gars
cas c'est le père noël comme ça mais ça
me rappelait plus du tc rappelez-vous
mais je me suis très bien passé mais
choquée moi et moi chaque fois que
j'arrive dans un pays de façon je sais
que je vais passer à plus de temps à la
droite
parce que bon moi je suis rien de
tunisie et donc on avait en main et tee
shirt mois la voilà et du coup on avait
nos tee shirt avec le drapeau de la
tunisie mais finalement comme on m'a vu
il aimait pas les théories de
l'attaquant la famille abbas est
sûrement là
c'était pas s'était pas vu ses 500 1000
et rouille c'est patent troll moi je
voulais raconter quand je suis arrivé
aux etats-unis jean grey je suis resté
ils m'ont parlé et je suis resté trois
heures avec à la police et à chaque fois
je suis ressorti d'un bureau ayant
narnia un autre mec
dès que je ressors après les faits sans
rigoler j'avais en fait j'avais acheté
parce que j'adore les séries je regarde
que les émissions de crimes tout ça et
j'avais acheté à l'aéroport à paris des
revues aulas est une revue qui s'appelle
criminals c'était une revue où il y
avait que des criminels en fait sur la
soul à je souhaite que chaque sur la
couverture est donc le mec arrive et ils
meurent foule est là ils prendront cette
fin what is it y avait un petit
s'acquitter je m'étais la gérer ça des
mecs qui n'ont etc pour une production
rapide 1
une fouille complète complète de ce hall
au plat les chéris oui défi est ce que
vous auriez préféré par exemple que la
chaîne n'ait fille diffuse tout ça pour
justifier le fait que vous avez des
difficultés peut-être pas tout ça mais
peut-être montré une petite partie en
expliquant le contexte les gens puissent
comprendre pourquoi voilà on ne voyait
pas peut-être à ce moment là pourquoi ma
way après vous comprenez que c'est pas
une émission polémique makes me voilà on
accepte ainsi que le racisme c'est
partout donc c'est pas quelque chose
qu'on vit pas au quotidien
donc après moi que je dénie par des sur
skins à ceux qui disent qu m6 à
dissumuler les images parce que c'est
pas dans l'adn de l'émission c'est pas
vrai en 2013 y avait une séquence de
racisme dans l'émission avec le jack
sans décharge on vous l'avait dit on
s'est revu les images c'était vraiment
une séquence de re a ses défauts il
déjoue ces images là mais en tout cas et
mes chéris kaoutar et nous jouer vous
dire merci d'avoir été là plaisir de
vous voir ainsi des bus est magnifique
on m'avait amené de larissa oui la
prochaine fois pour partir en fera pékin
express tous les trois aventure durera
six ans
pétri voilà et bah je suis pas sûr merci
d'avoir été là